>> Welcome to the Database and
the Data Analytics session.
This is of course
a very important area,
but not an entirely new area.
But today, we have
three excellent
speakers and they're
going to talk
about some of
the very new directions
that the field is taking.
So, one common trait among
them is the intersection of
this field with some
of the techniques in
Machine Learning.
The first two talks
that we are going to
hear are going to be around
leveraging some of these
Deep Analytic techniques for
some of the classical database
operations and challenges.
The last talk is going
to focus on saying
how can Data Analytic platforms
who are, of course,
for a long time and
traditionally have been
used to understand
what the data is,
what the insights in the data is,
can more easily adapt to
the challenges of doing
Machine Learning on
these platforms.
So, with these three talks,
you're going to see
both dimensions of
the work that's going on in
the field which is quite new.
So with that, we're
going to start with
the first speaker
who is Andy Pavlo.
Professor Andy
Pavlo is in CMU and
he is the leader of
the Database Group and the
Parallel Database
Laboratory there.
He's a winner of the SIGMOD
2014 Jim Gray Dissertation Award,
as well as the Sloan Research
Fellowship Award for
2018 and ACM SIGMOD
Best Paper Award.
In addition to
doing excellent and
innovative work in
database systems,
Andy is one of the most
entertaining speaker
and he has promised
us to kick off
this session on a high note.
With that Andy, take it away.
>> I promised you that I
wouldn't get you fired,
that's what I promised you.
>> That promise is also very
important and my manager
is in the audience,
so I have to be
particularly careful.
>> Right, okay. All
right. Thanks, Surajit.
So, I want to talk about
research we were doing at
Carnegie Mellon on
the context of how to
build autonomous or
self-driving database systems.
So, by autonomous, I mean
a database that's
able to configure,
tune and optimize itself
automatically without
any human intervention.
So, there's another talk
I could give about
the Machine Learning methods and
algorithms we use to
make this happen.
Instead, this talk,
I want to talk about
the things you need
to have when you're
building your database system in
order to make it amenable to
being tuned by
an autonomous component
or planning framework.
So, a way to think about
this, for this talk is,
these are the engineering
problems we have to overcome
in order to have the
Machine Learning
to stop being able to control us.
It doesn't matter how great
your Machine
Learning algorithms are,
how much training data you have,
if you actually cannot expose
the right interfaces or
API to those planning
frameworks and
then take the actions that
they suggest and apply them,
then all of it is for nothing.
So, today's talk, I'm going
to break it into three parts.
So first, let's talk about
some background of what
work's been done in
the context of
autonomous databases
for the last 40 years.
Then, we'll talk about more of
the engineering side of things,
again, how to support
Tom's operation.
Then, what kind of
database talk would I
give if we didn't finish off
with a rant about Oracle.
So, we'll finish up
with that. So, the idea
of autonomous
databases are almost
as old as databases themselves.
The first relational databases,
when they came out in the 1970s,
immediately people
recognized that
there was a need for these
systems to be able to adapt
themselves and optimize
the performance
of storage and indexing
without having a human
tell it everything.
So, back then, in the 1970s,
this line of work was called
self-adaptive systems.
It did things like
picking indexes,
it's probably
the most common one.
So, at a high-level,
these early self-adaptive tools
worked a lot like
they work today,
where you have some human
prepare a workload trace
of previous queries that
the application has executed and
then you're gonna feed them
into your tuning algorithm,
but then it's going
to crunch on them,
compute some internal statistics
about the problem
you're trying to solve.
So, if you're trying
to pick indexes,
you'll figure out what columns
are accessing those
often in queries.
Then, you use
this internal cost model
to evaluate a bunch of
candidate actions or
candidate indexes
and then weight them accordingly.
Then the tool would spit out
a recommendation to
a human who then
had to make the final
decision about how
and when to apply
it to the database.
So, at a high level again,
all of the self-adapted tools
work essentially the same way.
So they handle things
like index selection,
data partitioning, sharding
and data placement.
So, to just give you an idea
how old this problem is,
there's a paper in 1976
on doing self-adaptive
systems for index selection.
This paper was
actually written by
my advisor's advisor
who is now dead.
So, this again, people
will be thinking
about this for a long time.
So, now, the next
major trainer chapter in
autonomous systems came
along in the late
1990s and 2000s.
This entered the era of what
I'll call self-tuning databases.
Again, at a high, all these tools
are essentially doing
the same thing.
You take some workload
trace, crunch on
them and they spit
out recommendations.
So, all the major
vendors at this time
had their own proprietary tools
to solve these types of problems.
I'm not just saying this because
we're here at Microsoft,
but it's my opinion that
the AutoAdmin project by
Microsoft was at the vanguard,
really at the forefront of this.
There's a lot of
great groundbreaking work
that we're actually
building on today that
came out of this project.
The seminal paper would be
this 2007 paper from Surajit.
It talks about the decades worth
of work they did on this project.
So, the other thing we
saw in the self-tuning
systems around
this time was the need to
do knob configuration.
So, knob would be a
configuration parameter
you could set in
the system to control
the runtime behavior
of the database,
how much memory do you
use for your buffer pool.
So the reason why there was now
a need for automatic tools
to be able to configure
these things is
because the number
of knobs that these
systems actually
supported kept increasing and
things were getting more complex.
To give you an idea
how bad it is,
one of my students went and
took two major open-source
databases MySQL and
Postgres and went
back 15 years and
looked at all the
different releases and
counted the number of
knobs that they had.
In over a 15-year period,
Postgres increased
the number of knobs by
five x and MySQL increased
the number of knobs
they had by seven x.
So this point, this is well
beyond what any human
can reason about.
So, there's automated tools
that are needed to
make this happen.
So, now we see in
the 2010s we all
recall when we entered the era of
Cloud-managed databases.
This is exactly what we
just saw in the keynote,
where it was not so
much about how to tune
individual databases was now
at a service provider level,
how to essentially do
a bin packing problem.
How to place the tenants
on the various
hardware that you have
available in order to maximize
the performance by minimizing
your hardware costs,
and you may need to actually
migrate things over time.
So, this is again,
this is doing
autonomous databases,
but at the service
provider level or
the operative level where you're
not actually tuning
individual databases,
you're just looking at
thousands and thousands of
tenants and trying to
decide what's the best way
to lay them out.
So, now, given I just
spent this time,
the beginning, talking
about the last 40 years
of autonomous databases,
why is all this work that
people have done before,
why is this insufficient for
achieving a fully
autonomous system?
I'll say there's three
reasons why this is
not entirely what we need.
So, the first is that a lot of
these tools still
require a human to make
a final judgment about
the recommendations
or suggestions
from these tuning tools.
So, a human had to
look and say well,
"It's asked me to
build this index.
Is that actually the right
thing for me to do?"
Then the human actually
had to then decide
when it was the right time to
deploy that suggestion and
how should they deploy it.
So they had to know
that three AM on
a Sunday is when I have
the lowest amount of demand,
so that's when I go ahead
and start optimizing things.
The next problem is
that these are all
reactionary measures, a lot
of them are reactionary,
meaning they look at
the workload trace in the past,
identify problems and try to
cough suggestions and
avoid them in the future.
They're not looking down the road
looking at various trends
and saying, "Well,
this is what my workload
is going to look
like a week from now
or a month from now",
and prepare the
system accordingly.
This is essentially what
humans are doing now.
They do capacity planning
based on what
they think that the workload is
going to look like in the future.
The last problem is
that they're not,
not be able to transfer
any of the knowledge
that they learned from
tuning one particular database
and apply it to another database.
So what that means is that,
say I run my tuning tool or
my single database instance
and then I come
along with another application
I want to tune this database for,
unless that application has
exactly the same workload
on the exact same hardware,
you can't reuse anything you
learn from the first
time you ran it.
So, these are the
reasons why I think
all the existing work is not
enough in order to have
a fully autonomous system.
So, now you may be
asking why am I so
confident that it's going
to be different this time.
So, I would say
that the reason why
I'm optimistic about
our ability to have
a fully autonomous
system is essentially
the same story why Machine
Learning is hot now.
We have the storage capacity
actually store a lot of
training data and then we have
better frameworks like
Torch and TensorFlow,
even a crunch on it
and then we have
hardware accelerators like
GPUs and CPUs available to us,
to be able to take large amounts
of this training data
and derive the
models that we need.
So, this is why I'm
bullish on this area,
and I think that there's a lot
of interesting techniques
from Machine Learning and
the AI community that we
can apply for our databases
to essentially complete
the circle from what people
have done in the past.
So, to give you an idea
what some of these
projects look like,
I want to talk about
two things we've been
building at Carnegie Mellon
for the last couple of years.
The first is this thing
called OtterTune,
which is a knob configuration
tuning service.
This is designed to work on
existing systems like SQL
Server or MySQL Postgres,
and treating them as a black box,
and trying to figure out
what information can we
derive from them to help
our tuner knobs better.
Then we have another database
has been called Peloton,
we'll be burning
this from scratch,
where the idea is to take
a clean-slate approach
at designing
a database system
in order to make it
be managed by
an autonomous system.
So, I'll briefly go over
each of these one by one.
So, as I said, OtterTune is
a database knob
Tuning-as-a-Service.
The idea is, you come along
with your database installation,
you connect it to a service,
you upload some metrics,
we crunch on them, and then spit
back a knob recommendation,
and then we apply that observe
your changes and see
whether that helps.
In this feedback loop,
you get better and better.
The key difference
about OtterTune
than all the previous work,
is that we can actually
re-use the information,
or the data we've collected from
previous tuning sessions to
help speed up tuning
newer sessions.
So, that means if
you come along with
your application that we've
never seen it before,
but we collect some metrics and
we look to see how
it actually looks
very similar to this other
application we tuned in the past,
since we knew how
to tune that one,
now we know how to tune yours.
So, just as a quick show
what performance we can get,
so we did a simple
experiment where
we took MySQL and Postgres,
we ran the TPCC benchmark on
a small instance on Amazon.
We're going to compare
what OtterTune can
do against the default
configuration you
get for these systems versus
some open-source tuning scripts,
or the configuration you get from
Amazon when you run an RDS,.
Then lastly, we're also
going to compare it against
very expensive human DBAs
tuning these two
systems manually.
So, in the case of MySQL
what you see is that,
the OtterTune and the DBA
actually performed better than
all the other approaches.
Now, the reason why the DBA
actually beats us here,
is because this is the top
MySQL DBA from Facebook,
and there's some knob
in MySQL that affects
whether you flush every
right when each
commit a transaction,
or how aggressive
you flush things.
At Facebook, they were
okay with turning
that feature off so that it
allows you get a little bit
better performance.
This is actually
an important point when
we talk about
the engineering side,
because this actually
a human judgment
has to be made about whether it's
okay to reduce the durability
of your transactional data.
So, we blacklisted
this knob from OtterTune.
So, we purposely said it's
not allowed to tune this,
and then that's why the DBA
was actually able to beat us.
In the case of Postgres,
we see the OtterTune
actually does
better than all the
other approaches,
and this is because it's able
to find the sweet spot for
this particular workload and
harbor configuration for
tuning the buffer pool size,
that's the log file size.
This again, we're up against
a very seasoned DBA,
and we are able to beat them.
Again, the main thing here is
that OtterTune is doing as good,
if not better than
very expensive human DBAs,
with only training
for about an hour.
Now, the next project is Peleton,
and we're pitching this as
the self-driving database system.
Meaning that we want
this thing to be
entirely autonomous.
So, we're building this
from the ground up to be
entirely controlled
by this self-driving framework
we've been building.
The idea here is
that we want to see,
what advantage do we have when
we have complete control
of the entire system?
How it allows to do things that
we cannot easily
do with OtterTune.
What I'll say, is that we
actually considered maybe
using MySQL Postgres
initially for this project,
but what we found is
that there's just way
too many things that require
the system to restart,
have other problems
that make it not
amenable for
self-driving operation.
So, we decided to bite the bullet
and write a system from scratch.
There's a whole other talk I can
give about the trials and
tribulations of building
a database system
from scratch in academia,
which is been quite a journey.
So now, I want to talk
about what I'm calling
design considerations for
autonomous operation.
So again, the idea here is that,
how should you build
a database system
in order to support itself,
to have itself to be
able to be controlled
by planning framework that
wants to run entirely
autonomously.
So, for this,
the re-occurring theme that
we see over and over again,
is that these
engineering decisions
we can make are going to help
us reduce the complexity
of the solution space
for our autonomous
planning components.
Because, otherwise
we need a lot of
training data in order
to train these models,
and it'll take
a long time for them
to converge to a good solution.
So, there's some tricks we can do
to reduce the number
of choices we have to
consider and maximize the reuse
of the training data that
we want to build upon,
and that allows us to get
better optimizations
more quickly.
So, I'll first start talking
about configuration
knobs and metrics,
so the idea is here's
what API or data you
expose to the planning framework,
and then we'll talk
about how do you take
the actions that
the planning framework suggests,
and apply them in
an efficient manner without
slowing down the rest
of the system.
All right.
So, the most important thing
you have to have for
your configuration knobs is
the ability to mark which
ones should or should not
be tuned by your
autonomous components.
We saw this before when we
talked about the Facebook DBA.
There's some flag that
Facebook allowed
their DBA's to set,
that we decided that
we weren't going to
set in our autonomous
components because
a human had to make
a final value judgment
about whether it was
okay to do that.
So, some things are obvious.
Like file parse, network
addresses, and port numbers,
but if you don't set
these things then system
doesn't boot properly at all.
But things like durability
and isolation levels,
these are actually judgments
that have to be made by
the company organization about
whether that was
an okay thing to do.
Is it okay to turn off async
when you commit a transaction?
Are you okay with losing the last
10 to 20 milliseconds
worth of transaction data?
Some places, that's okay,
some places that's not okay.
But the machine learning
algorithms aren't
going to do that.
There's some other more nuance
things like harbor usage,
like how aggressive
you want to be
doing compaction if
you have an LSM.
Because this will cause you
to wear down the device
more quickly and have
to buy new hardware.
Recovery time is another one,
like how long are you
willing to have the system
to take to recover
if there is a crash?
We can't control
these things or we
can't know these things in
our Machine Learning
model across models.
So, we have to have a human to be
able to tell us and therefore,
we need to blacklist him.
The next is one is
that we need now
hints about how we should
actually tune these knobs.
Again, this is necessary
again to reduce
the search space or
solution space of the actions
that we could apply
in our system.
So, the most obvious one, is
our min-max ranges
for a parameter.
How much memory should I be able
to allocate to a buffer pool?
There's other things we
see that any time you have
a knob that you think
can't be controlled,
meaning turn it on and off,
you should always
separate them from
the actual knob that
controls its behavior.
So, sometimes we see
knobs where you can rate
them how fast it's going write
data at the desk in
terms of kilobytes.
But a lot of times, you'll
use a special value like
negative one or zero to
disable that feature.
The problem is, the
Machine Learning algorithm
will find that setting,
the amount of data
you're reading out
the disc to zero kilobytes
makes it go faster.
Of course, that now that
means you're not writing
data to disk, and you're
going to lose data.
So, if you just have a separate
boolean flag to control
it separately from
the actual parameter,
that makes things easier.
Another more nuanced one
is the ability to
control how you actually
modify these values are knobs.
So, in most cases,
in those systems we've seen,
you can set absolute values
for a certain parameter.
Like how much memory you want to
use for your buffer pool,
you can set it from 0 to 32.
We think the better way
to do this is just have
increments that
are based on delta
that go up and down
for these parameters,
and that cuts down the number of
actions you have to consider.
But now the problem is,
if you have a large range
of values you could choose,
then incrementing
by a fixed amount
throughout that entire range
causes problems.
So, what you really want is
non-uniform deltas like this.
So, say if I want to
set the amount of
memory of music in
my buffer pool,
if I'm between one kilobyte
and one megabyte,
maybe just increment by
100 kilobytes at a time.
But if I'm up that
one terabyte of DRAM,
I don't want to increment
by one kilobytes,
because it's not going
to get big difference
from one setting to the next.
So, you can expose the deltas
to the tuning algorithms,
and say only increment by
these values when you're
within these ranges.
Now, the next thing we're
going to talk about is,
how do you expose metrics or
information to
the outside system,
and we are going to use these
to build our cost models,
and do reward calculations for
our actions we can choose.
So, the most important
thing we find,
is that anytime your database
system supports
the ability to tune
individual sub-components,
you are going to
make sure you expose
individual metrics for
the sub-components.
So, an example
would be in my DB2,
you can set the number of
buffer pools you want,
and for each buffer pool you
can tune them separately.
You need to make sure that
for each buffer pool,
all of the stats you care
about are exposed to you,
and not so aggregated together.
The biggest offender we find is
actually for this, is RocksDB.
So, in RocksDB, you can set,
for each table you can have
multiple column families.
You tune each column
family individually.
So, they do expose
some metrics about each
column family, but the problem,
is the most important thing
you need to determine whether
your performances
get better or worse
are the number of reads and
writes per column family.
But they're not included in
the subcomponent metrics.
Instead, you can only get this
from a global metric table,
where it's been
combined together.
So, now you need a lot
of training data
in order to determine
whether the changes
you're making to
one particular column family
is benefiting or hurting you,
because you have to
then extract that
from the aggregated metric.
So, now we are going to talk
about how do you actually
take the actions that
the album select and
apply them efficiently.
So the most important
thing I would say,
and part of the reason why with
Peloton we decided to build
a system from scratch,
is that we find that
many cases changing
a knob or applying
an action requires you
to restart the system in order
for that to take effect.
Now the commercial
systems are much
better than this than
the open-source guys,
but even the SQL
server Oracle and DB2,
there's enough knobs in there
that require you to
have to restart.
The reason why that's
problematic is because now
you need to take
into consideration,
in your cost models,
the time it takes to
restart the system.
Or you have to ask a human
whether it's okay to restart
the system right now.
So, we think that there should be
never any knob that will
require you to have
to restart and this
includes scaling up the hardware,
as well as applying changes that
modify how it actually
uses the hardware.
Another very important thing is
that you want to have
the ability to have
your replicas diverge and have
different configurations,
in order to get
more training data about
the different configurations
you could have.
Alright, so a very common setup
and databases is that for
high availability
you have a master
and some replicas, right?
And anytime the master
goes down then you
elect one of the replicas
to become the new master.
So, normally you would
have these things
have the exact same
configuration because
anytime to master
goes down you want
the replica to be able
to come up right away.
But instead what you can do
to get more training data,
you could have the master had
the best configuration
you ever seen,
but in your replicas you're
trying out other
configurations see
whether they're actually better
than what's on the
master right now.
So in this case here,
the replicas could be
trying out different
index selections,
and seeing whether
they're actually
improving performance.
Let's say for this top guy here,
this is actually doing
better than we can recognize
that it's okay for us to
deploy this on the master.
Right? The reason why
we want to do this in
the replica is we
don't want to slow
down the master node
because we need to meet
our SLAs and SLOs.
So now the problem is though,
let's say that this bottom guy
here we're trying out
a configuration that
actually is bad and
therefore we're
falling behind the workload
that's on the master.
Right? So, we recognize
now we are too far behind
we want to go ahead
and kill that configuration and
restart the system because we
don't want to have to crash,
if the master crashes,
we don't want to replica have to
take five minutes to
get caught backup
because now that's downtime
we have to include in our system.
>> [inaudible]
>> Yes. Perfect. So,
there's a bunch of
other stuff you have to
consider for this like can you,
if you're in a Cloud environment,
can you scale out additional
BMs to collect more
training data.
How do you generate
the workloads,
so you're the input sequence
to the replicas are different?
Right? So, there's a whole bunch
of assistance questions
to actually make this work
and I think it's interesting.
So, to finish up let's
talk about Oracle.
You might have seen
this announcement last year,
were Oracle came out and says,
"We have the world's first
self-driving Database
Management System".
Larry Ellison got on
stage and he said,
"This is the most
important thing that
the Oracle Corporation has
worked on in the last 20 years".
So, the other thing about
this announcement is
that we had a paper in January,
a few months before, where we
talked about our self-driving
database system,
and at no point did
Larry Ellison mention our work.
So, I decided to
shoot him an email and
I'm like "Hey look,
what's up with that, right?"
Now, you may be
thinking it's puerile
for a professor to email
somebody and say "Hey,
why didn't you cite our work?",
But Larry Ellison and I
go pretty far back
and so I thought it
was okay for me to
email and let them know
that I was slightly
displeased with this.
Now, he didn't respond
to this email.
He never responds to
any of my emails,
but that's okay we
can still break
it down and see what
he's actually done.
So, their self-driving database
claims that they have for
key features: They do
automatic indexing,
recovery, scaling,
and query tuning.
Now for the first
three items here,
these are essentially
the same things
solving the same kind
of problems that
the self tuning databases we're
solving in the 2000s, right?
And so in talking with
the Oracle developers,
and reading their
marketing material,
as far as I can tell these
are just the same tools that
they've been selling before
as DBAs for the DBAs,
but now just running them
in a managed environment.
So that means they have
the same limitations or
problems that I talked about
before where they
are reactionary,
and they're not able to
do knowledge transfer.
So, for this reason,
I don't think this
is actually really
self-driving databases.
They're just running your stuff
automatically and playing tricks,
the colors to make it look like
it's fully adaptive
and self-driving.
So now, for the last one
Automatic Query Tuning,
ff you're familiar with the
work in academic literature,
this is usually referred to
as Adaptive Query Processing.
The idea is if you have
a very expensive Query,
you run it through the optimizer
when you first start,
you generate a query plan and
if you notice over
time as you're running
it things it's not as good
as you thought it was,
then you run to
the optimizer again.
This is not unique to Oracle.
Microsoft announced last year,
in Sequel Server 2017,
that they have the same feature,
but it's even older
than that, right?
If you go back into
the early 2000s,
IBM DB2 had a project called
Leo the Learning Optimizer,
where they were essentially
doing the same kind of thing,
but it's even older
than the IBM project.
It actually goes back to
the 19070s with the first,
one of the first relational
databases Ingress,
where they are
essentially, they are
running the query optimizer,
over and over again for every
single Tuple you would examine,
and they did this not
because they were
trying to be sophisticated,
they were doing this because they
had a really primitive
query optimizer.
So, again in this case here
there's nothing really
unique about what Oracle
is claiming they can do,
and I wouldn't say that this
is self-driving at all.
What I will say
though, that Oracle is
in talking with developers,
they are working on
a newer version of this that
is certain to incorporate some of
the things that I'm
talking about here.
So to finish up, I think that
autonomous databases are
achievable in the next decade.
I think it's a lot
of engineering work,
a lot of systems research,
and a lot of machine
learning stuff we can
apply to make this
thing all work.
I would say for anybody that's
working on a large system,
they wonder how it would be used,
whether it's in academia
or in industry.
Anytime you add a new feature,
you should not think about how
that human going to tune this,
you should really be
thinking about how can
a machine tune this in
an efficient manner.
I'm I exposing the right
information and if I have
the right controls that are
necessary to make
this thing work.
So with that I'll finish up
and I don't think we have
any questions right?
Because we'll do
a panel afterwards.
Okay? Thank you.
>> Thanks Andy. Just
hang in for a second.
Let's see if there
are a couple of
pointed questions that anybody
in the audience has for Andy,
before the memory of the talk
fades a bit with
the next two talks.
So if you have any
questions though,
raise your hand there
are runners who will get
you a microphone because
these talks are being recorded.
>> Yes. I'll repeat the question
and it makes it easier.
>> Yeah.
>> Andy, thanks for
the great talk.
So, you mentioned a bunch of
driving factors like there
being like available
new hardware and
available new interesting ways of
doing more powerful models
such as Steve nuts.
But from from
my experience one of
the big differentiators
is also the availability
of new data or of more data
that allows us to do
better training and therefore
build better and much
expressive models.
So, I'm wondering where do you
get your data from and you
have any interesting
insights of how
to do better and more
targeted data collection
and selection for training
better models in this context?
>> So, his question is that,
so Yohannes is arguing that
the having a lot of training data
is the key thing to
having models that
actually we can derive use from.
So, what are some things
we can do to
improve the collection in
training data? Is that correct?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So, the one thing I
said before is about
this example here,
if you use your
replicas to try out
different configurations this is
collecting more training data.
But this this is helping you to
converge to see whether
you're actually getting
benefit from
the choices you make.
In terms of the actual
metrics I think that,
the systems are doing
monitoring now,
we just make sure
that we push them
out and build our models
based on them.
So, there's not really
anything in terms
of what metrics you collect,
not really anything
in there that's
different than what
existing systems do now.
In the case of Auto-Tune,
we don't actually need to look at
the queries or
the actual data itself,
we just take the metrics,
the internal performance
counters that
the system generates
and spits them out.
The other thing I'll say
though is a lot of times
developers just add whenever
metric they think off, right?
So, there's a lot of
data that it's actually
not really useful.
So, we have
statistical methods to
sort of prune out the
things that actually don't
matter and focus on
the main ones and
they find the signal and
the noise in that way.
>> Carlos?
>> Yes.
>> Hey. [inaudible]
can you hear me?
>> I can hear you.
>> Okay. Can you
repeat the question.
>> I will.
>> So [inaudible]
the question is,
I think there is a mental
advantage for a Cloud provider.
Millions of databases.
So, how do you
see a way for
academia to collaborate
with our providers since,
we will have the data, and
we'll obviously want to do
this kind of research because
all of the advantages
you described.
But, how do you give
academia a shot basically
to help us innovate
on this, right?
Giving out data is
obviously very hard.
Do you have any ideas of how,
beside interns, we
can make this work?
Otherwise we adapt
the web search in which there is
one or two companies in the
world that do it and everyone
else can talk about
something else?
>> So, which company
are you working for,
or are you in the academia
recently John?
>> I think the
advantage is for us.
I'm just wondering how we can-
>> All right. I think
Carlo's question is,
how should academics engage
with major Cloud vendors
like Microsoft,
and try to apply some of
these techniques in
your environment?
So, this is why divided
my two projects in
taking existing systems versus
building the system from scratch.
For the kind of tuning we
want to hand on Auto-Tune,
you need to have the source code,
you need complete control
of everything.
So, I think for you guys it
will be hard to do this,
plus SQL server is
a huge code base.
I think that is something
you guys have to do in-house.
With Auto-Tune, since
we're just looking at,
treating the database system
as a black box,
I think interns are probably
the right way to do this.
I think that we've
learned enough about SQL server
now and other systems
that we come to you guys,
and say, "Hey if you
add these features",
but the things we're
going to ask you for,
is going to taking
longer than you
can do in a summer internship.
So, I don't know what
the right approach is for that.
>> So, I would just add
one small thing that,
it is true that we get
a lot of telemetric data.
>> Yes.
>> There is no question.
But as you know,
we are not allowed to look
at the data or the workload.
So, even though there is a lot of
data in our Cloud service
somewhere we're not
entitled to look at it,
that query string or actual data,
unless the customer has raised
a ticket and for
a limited time and audited,
where somebody looks at it.
So, it comes with
the other balancing thing
on our ability to,
in classical way, look
at all the data like
Bing or Google can
do, we can't do.
I think, just wanted to add that.
>> So, as in aside, I
will say that again,
I'm not just here
because he's here.
Just the way that AutoAdmin was
the leader in this area
in the 2000s,
in my visits with companies,
I think Microsoft again,
in the Cloud area,
is leading this effort.
I'm actually surprised
at how primitive some of
the things that are out there
in major Cloud vendors
in this area.
>> Well, last question.
Thanks, Andy. Then,
maybe the last question.
>> I can ask question.
So Andy, you mentioned-
>> We can't hear you, but I
think the microphone is not on.
I think that microphone.
>> Can you hear me now?
>> I can hear you,
I'll just repeat it.
>> Right. So,
my question was that,
you mentioned that there was
an increase in the number of
contradition knobs in
these various database engines,
by what, a factor of
five over the years.
But it's likely that
most of the features
don't really affect the
performance as such,
in the sense that the same
three or four
important parameters
that were there ten years back,
would probably be the same
ones that you have right now.
So, actually only the DBA
needs to look at
those parameters,
and the rest of them are
just as you have mentioned,
nice amongst the signal.
If you are using
machine learning techniques,
it's likely that
you will introduce
many new features that
are actually not relevant
towards the final goal
of optimizing the
system for performance.
>> So, his question is that in
this graph here I'm showing
that there's 100 of knobs.
But in actuality, most of them
are probably not something
that a DBA is going
to tune actively
or tune in a daily job.
Then, you are saying
that if now we
start interfacing the data system
with machinery pieces or
machinery components,
that is going to
introduce more knobs and
more complexity, and
how do we handle that?
So, for the first one,
I would say that what we
do in Auto-Tune is that,
we basically run a similar
less of aggression and
figure out here is
the ranking of the knobs that
actually matter the most
for a variety of workloads.
You are right, it
is about 25 or so.
But I would say that it's
more than just the
number of knobs,
it is the dependencies
between them,
and that just makes the
problem much more difficult.
The second thing you
said was that adding in
machine learning parts makes
this thing even harder to tune.
I would say, yes.
My lofty research goals,
I think we can omit all of us.
I don't think we actually
need humans to do very,
very much other than to give
us a credit card number
and some initial hints
about how to tune things.
I don't think there is anything
that we would need a human
to tune these things for.
So, that's my goal,
whether we get there in 10 years,
I like to think we
can, but we'll see.
>> Well on that high note,
thank you, Andy.
>> Thank you.
>> So, our next speaker is
Professor Tim Krasca from MIT.
Tim has been in
our field of delivery system
for a long time,
and his research has focused
in the past on hybrid,
I guess in the present as well,
human-machine delivery systems
and big data management.
Most recently though, he has
been taking a very
bold agenda which
is to go and look at the
database systems architecture,
which is not exactly young,
and say that maybe using data and
machine learning techniques
we can take a hard look at
these component and see
how can be architected?
How can they be even better
than what it has
been traditionally?
I think we are going to
hear some of that today.
I also wanted to say that
he has had many awards,
I have mentioned some of them,
he has IEEE Data Engineering
Best Paper Award in
2013 and the Sloan
Fellowship Award 2017,
and most recently
he is the winner of
the 2018 VLDB Early Career
Research Contributions Award.
With that, Tim take it away.
>> Thank you.
>> Thanks.
>> Thanks. Can you all hear me?
In the back as well?
It's all good?
Perfect. So, what I am
going to talk about is
actually a paper we
published this year in SIGMOD
called The Case for
Learned Index Structures.
Half of the talk, if you
have seen it maybe before,
particularly the
Microsoft people,
you know it already.
However, I also added
some new stuff with it on
multidimensional indexes
for the second half.
So, you can fall asleep
for the first 10 minutes.
The work we published in
SIGMOD mode actually
went viral last year.
It all started with a tweet
by Christopher Manning
saying that
"Machine Learning Just Ate
Algorithms In One Large Bite".
I just want to give
a disclaimer here up front,
we by no means believe that
machine learning has eaten
the whole field of algorithms
and data structures.
However, we do believe maybe
it has taken a little bit
from it and there's a lot
of more interesting
work to be done.
So, why are people
so excited about it?
The fundamental building
blocks essentially,
of all systems in particular
to data management system,
are data structure
and algorithms.
We have a whole range
of really of
this fundamental data structures
from different
sorting algorithms,
HashMaps, different
types of indexes,
priority queues and so on.
All these data structures
have in common that they
essentially make
no assumptions about the data.
So, now let me give you
just a very simple example.
Let's assume that in
your database system,
you want to store and
carry all integers
from 900-800 million.
You are interested in
range queries for them,
you are looking into
scanning for example,
all the integers from 100 to
something and
their coding records.
So, very simple example.
In this particular case,
probably nobody here would
actually use a B-tree for it
because it's you know that
has all the integers
in that range.
Instead, what you
could do is from
an index structure just
like the lookup key
itself as an offset.
So what you do is just
lookup into your datastore.
The Lookup key minus 900,
which gives you the offset,
and you can then
immediately start
reading because you know
something about
the data distribution.
So, now assume that you store
all even integer numbers from
900-800 million and
the same trick still works.
You take your lookup key
minus 900 divided by two,
which gives you again the offset
and you can look
it immediately up.
So, what we did here
is essentially,
we had the B-tree before,
which has a lock and lookup time.
So, you need to
traverse this and now
transform it to something
that is essentially over.
This still holds true for
other data distributions as long
as you know the empirical
data distribution and
can compactly represent it.
So, the key insight
is that if you take
this black box of the data
and now just making
the black box by saying,
okay, if you know something about
your empirical data distribution,
about the data you store,
you can put much,
much better data
structures for them.
In some cases, even transform
the complexity class.
Now obviously, it's not efficient
to build one system from
scratch for every single
used case you have.
This is not economical,
but this is exactly where
machine learning comes in
because it provides us
the toolbox to learn these types
of models and then take
afterwards advantage of them.
So, here I will use
B-trees as a main example,
and just for
simplicity right now,
I assume that we have
an in-memory immutable B-tree.
There's no inserts and no paging.
Just for simplification, I will
talk about inserts
and paging later on.
So, if you think what
a B-tree actually does is,
given a key, the B-tree
finds you the position
inside the sorted array.
Normally, we page
the sorted array,
meaning that we put it into
different pages, and
then for example,
your only index is the first
key inside the page,
just for efficiency reasons
that the B-tree doesn't
blow entirely up.
So, in that sense,
what a B-tree does given the key,
it finds me the page.
Then, I need to search inside
the page to find the extra key.
So, it's already
an approximate data structure
because given a key,
you get the position inside
the sorted array
and then you have
to search inside the page size.
So, it's a guarantee that
you will find it there.
In that sense, I can actually
replace the B-tree with a model,
as long as I have the right key
and the model predicts
me the position where
this key might be inside
the assorted array, I'm good.
Now, the question is
just like the first,
how do I still get
the guarantee that I can still
find my key inside
the sorted array? Where is it?
Like in the previous case,
the page defined
the mini-max error of
where to find the key.
First of all, it's actually
surprisingly simple.
So, let's assume I have a
monotonically increasing model,
what that means is just,
I can run every key through
the model and then look
on how far it is off,
and simply remember the maximum
over and under prediction,
which gives me
a strong error bond.
In the end, it sorts out
but we don't even need that
because given that the whole
thing is sorted anyway,
I get a prediction and then
I can do something like
exponential search
to find actually
the key right in place,
wherever it is, without
needing to search everything.
I can get the bound and
then with the bound,
I could do binary search,
if I don't have the bound,
I could do something
like exponential steps.
So, it turns out what
we're actually doing here,
is the index, is like
modeling the CDF of the data.
So, given a key,
it finds me the position
inside the sorted array,
which is just nothing else
than trying to estimate
the probability mass of
every key which is
equal or less than the
key I'm looking up,
times, and the numbers
of keys I have in total,
which gives me the position
inside the sorted array.
This insight is
interesting because
this allows us to
take advantage of
this whole literature out there
on how CDFs can be modeled.
Even more interesting, is that
a B-tree itself can also be
seen as a model already.
It's a form of a regression tree,
and it's just like a special
form of a special structure,
but it's also a model.
So, there's nothing that even,
but we do right now you can
actually see as models,
I'm just saying you can
use other things as well.
So, what does it mean,
and that makes potentially
some people here very happy,
that is database people
were actually the
very first to do large-scale
Machine Learning.
Right? Because we were
the first to do large B-trees,
which is nothing else
than building a model.
So, what might be
the potential of using
other models than the normal
regression trees or B-trees?
There are a whole bunch of them.
First of all, they might lead to
smaller indexes if for example,
in the case before, if we know
we have all the integers,
I can build a much more
compact representation of it.
The only thing I need
to select the offset.
Maybe an intercept, and
the slope, and I'm done.
It's much more space efficient.
I might get faster lookups.
I might get more parallelism,
and that is mainly
because for many models,
I'm transforming the
very heavy if statements
B-tree needs to traverse
into multiplications
and additions.
I might be able to
take advantage of
hardware accelerators,
and we heard in
the morning already that
there's a lot of
excitement going on
in building FPGAs especially
for Machine Learning.
So, now, by transforming them,
I might have been advantaged
to actually leverage them
also for database systems.
There's also a chance of
having a shipper inserts,
I will talk about that later.
So, we tried that out very early
on like after having
this observation in TensorFlow.
So, we built a TensorFlow ReLU,
two layer fully connected,
certitude, ReLU activated.
We treated over 200 million
web-server log records,
we wanted to do
index a timestamp,
and essentially the goal
of the integrals was
giving me a times,
and it gave me the position
inside the sorted array.
So, a cash optimized
B-tree for this task,
roughly takes 250 nanoseconds.
Any guesses how long
TensorFlow takes?
The first attempt 80,000.
So, this successfully we made
just almost three
orders of magnitudes,
a little bit more slower,
and it's not very successful.
The reason for them
are very manifold.
First of all, TensorFlow is
designed for very large models,
not for these tiny
things which are
supposed to run in
the range of nanoseconds.
The search doesn't take advantage
that we actually get pretty
close by the prediction,
but often our minimax error
is very, very large.
It's like most of the time
we actually close by,
so if you binary search
this throws you off.
Then B-trees are very
cache efficient.
So, if you have a large model,
you lose that as well, plus
they are great for overfitting.
In this case, overfitting,
as long as you only have
lookups and all inserts
is actually a good thing,
because as more you overfit,
you better look up
your data you have.
Here, I am only
addressing the last two,
because I need them later on to
explain how a multidimensional
indexes work.
So, to overcome the
problem that we have,
a very efficient way to
overfit to something,
we came up with this structure
which we call the
recursive model index,
but you can best think
of it's just like
an expert model where one model,
the top one, picks
another model which was
an expert for
certain range of the data.
Right. So, we have one
model at the top which
takes the key,
makes a prediction,
based on the prediction,
you pick another model
which no set area better,
which might pick another
model. All right.
So, the nice thing about that is,
it can be very
efficiently implemented.
Let's assume I have
a top model f 0.
F, models on stage two,
that's just an array of models.
So, what I'm actually doing,
is just like I execute
the first model which gives me
an index position into
the array of models
of the second stage,
which then can execute
which gives me
the final position if I
have a two stage model.
If I now, for everything
don't use neural nets,
but let's assume just
like linear regression,
the whole lookup, as you can see
down here takes me
two multiplies,
two additions, and
one area look up.
This is the execution of
the index, that's it.
There's some code necessary
for boundary checks,
but it turns out you
can also avoid that.
You just need to change
the learning a little
bit so that the boundaries
to do checks whenever necessary.
Furthermore, you can,
in some cases even
replace some of the modes
using normal B-trees.
Right. So, if you say, "Okay,
in a certain area
the normal linear model,
or neural net, or
whatever you are using,
everything is fair game
doesn't work very well."
So, just replace that piece
of it using a normal B-tree,
and you get the normal
guarantees for it.
The nice thing of doing that,
is the worst case performance in
the end is the one of
just like the B-tree,
because from the worst-case
just re-grates to a B-tree.
We started out with that it turns
out like it most of
data sets right now,
we never use that anymore,
because the complexity of mixing
different models normally
doesn't pay off.
It's easier to just
use more models.
So, it doesn't have
to be neural-nets.
The answer is clearly, no.
You can use whatever fits and
this is essentially what
we are doing right now.
We normally use
very simple linear models,
sometimes multi-variant models.
In particular cases,
there are more complex
data is required,
sometimes neural-nets,
but very simple ones.
The neural nets' are actually
the most complicated things
are the activation function,
because they are
often very expensive
to execute on the CPU.
So, it doesn't work.
What we did here, is just like we
compared to a cash optimized,
and read optimized Be-tree
tuned out to get
the best lookup performance,
and compared to
our learned indexes,
and what you see
is just overall we
get up to a factor of two
faster and save up
to one order or even
more in main memory.
We also compared us against
other states of
that index structures,
for example files,
look-up tables,
fixed size B-trees with
interpolation search,
and here it plucks
the alternatives
in regard to lookup-Time
versus size.
The left lower corner is
where you want to be,
and you can see that
the learned indexes
is like a dominant solution.
So what about like
our assumption I did in
the beginning about
'Inserts' and 'Paging'.
First of all, 'Inserts' might not
be such a big problem in that.
So let's assume that
your 'Inserts' follow
roughly the data distribution
what you have learned.
In that sense, you don't need to
rebalance the model, right.
You don't need to change it.
You can just reuse
the model and make
space wherever you want
to insert something.
This is particularly
easy to see if
you have mostly like 'Inserts'.
Let's assume you have
timestamps for IoT devices.
The timestamps normally increase.
It might increase with
the same patterns
what you have
observed in the past,
so the model simply generalizes.
As a B-tree, you have to
rebalance all the time.
Of course, the big
question becomes if it
doesn't follow exactly
the data distribution,
how do you still rebalance?
But there's something like robust
machine learning which
takes care of that,
so there are
new approaches there.
The second question
is like paging.
Often what we have is just
that we want to page there,
particularly if it's on disk.
Here, one simple solution
is actually that you
use the model itself to
determine the pages.
So normally, a B-tree
re-takes what goes
into a page, right.
Like if you have
index-organized table,
the index tells you what
you should put on the page,
you can do the same thing here,
and then you get around most of
the problems you would
have otherwise as paging.
So we started with B-trees,
but it turned out
like the same idea
also applies to many,
many other data
structures, from 'Join',
'Sorting', "Hash-Map'
'Bloom-Filters', 'Priority Queues'.
For example, one of
my colleagues, Mohammed,
is working on a new learn
scheduling algorithms
for data analytics.
There's work on
cache policies by Google.
We are looking into query
optimization, what
we can do there.
There's a whole range
where you can
apply very similar ideas.
Most of the time, it's
all about learning
the CDF of your data and
taking advantage of that.
So here, I just want to mention
something else which is
multidimensional indexes.
So, our big hope when we
started that actually was not
to get more efficient
index structures for
a single dimension.
Our hope was always like, okay,
the moment we will
go multidimensional,
we assumed we would see
the bigger benefits there,
because with machine
learning in general
or most of the modes are really,
really good in, it's
just like capturing
all the complex relationship
data half, right?
So, machine learning was
just like predefined to say like,
"Okay, it should perform very
well on multidimensional data."
The biggest problem we faced in
the beginning is just
that unfortunately,
even if we learn
all these complex correlations,
in the end, there
is only one auto
on disk, which is
one-dimensional.
Of course, you can see like
this become more complex,
but in the end, you have
like one order for scanning.
This is like big
fundamental limitations
on how you deal with it
because at some point,
it doesn't matter how you do it,
you need to transform
what you have in
the multidimensional space
to one order on disk,
and this is like in
the end what matters,
or one order you
have in main memory.
So how can you do that?
So, let's assume those are like
the different data
points you have.
Let's assume that this is
maybe some order data.
You have the order amount
and order Zip Code,
and those are like two-dimensions
you make queries for.
One approach you could say okay,
if the the two attributes are
equally important to you,
you project them just
through the middle,
you can see is a form of PCA
because you give each
the equal weight,
and then you have one projection
to a one-dimensional space,
and this is like the sorting
order you use on disk.
You can immediately
see in some cases,
this is like fine, and others,
this will never work very well.
For example, if you know
that most of the queries you
do are for the Order Amount
and not for the Order Zip Code,
the best thing you
can actually do
is you order all your data
regarding the Order Amount
and disregard the
Zip Code for that.
If you mostly lookup
for Zip Codes,
you would do the opposite.
You order everything for Zip Code
but you ignore the Order Amount.
So, there's a trade-off
in how you actually
serialize the data and
how you lay it out.
So, the interesting thing is we
found that you can
actually even mix them.
For example, you can say okay,
I project on to Zip Code,
then I built larger blocks,
and though within a block,
maybe I want to use
a different projection,
in this case Order Amount.
So, I first split up into
Zip Codes and then I project
down to Order Amount.
So, I have like
every block is now ordered
within regarding to
the Order Amount.
And again, I can trade them
off on how they depend,
and what's best highly
depends on your workload.
If you never touched
the Zip Code,
you should probably not order for
them because it doesn't
provide you any benefit.
This led to our final design.
Right now, what we have for
multidimensional indexes,
is we start out with
the data points we have.
We have the first model which
is called the 'Projector',
which based on the workload,
projects it into an order
we have later on on disk.
What we do there is exactly
the trick I showed you before.
We allow columns on how we
split it down to this
in this like blocks.
So we start with the root node
which figures out
the general direction of the data
depending on what cruise
they are most common,
then it projects everything
to this dimension.
Then we repeat
the process and make
directions projections for
all the different blocks
separately again.
Often they're orthogonal to each
other just because on
how the data's lay out.
So we get like for example
these projections down
here that you can see now
like this in every block,
we have actually
a different order
of them, and therefore,
like models of models
again to define or find
some point in that space
later on on the disk.
Also interesting, this can be
recursed so you can make
it as deep as you want.
And this model itself here is
the same data structure
that's what I
showed you before for RMI.
This is like again,
this expert model on the top
which picks another expert
which organizes this differently.
This, if you have
only linear models,
can be executed again for
two-stage models
and two multiplies,
two additions and
one error lookup.
So it's extremely fast.
However, if you
have the Projector,
it still doesn't give us
now like where to find
something in a dense array
because still,
there might be space in between.
So what we do in order to get
the dense array is nothing
else than what we had before.
It's just like build a Locator
again using an RMI model.
So, this is like essentially,
we have everything in
one-dimensional space,
and now, we built like
the same B-tree model what
we had before all that.
So, this is pretty new,
but some very rare initial
performance number
shows it's pretty promising.
So, for one million
data points right now,
you get roughly 200 nanosecond
lookups for point queries.
This is like a speedup of
two to 10 X over the R-Trees,
depending on how you
are configure it while
you have like an order of
magnitude space savings.
Of course, there's more to come.
We need more workloads,
and this is essentially,
this lookup here is
without considering
the workload itself yet,
because we haven't
done that even though,
it just assumes everything
is uniformly likely,
which is actually
the worst case scenario for us.
Also interesting to note is,
this data structure
in contrast to
an R-Tree doesn't increase
with the numbers of
dimensions you have.
Instead, it should increase
with the rank of the data.
So, if you have for example,
at the same attribute again,
just a full duplicate,
it wouldn't make any change to
our layout or the
model complexity.
So, for future work,
there's much more to be done,
we are heavily looking
into sorting and joining.
So essentially, what we want
to figure out, is just,
can we not improve
every single component of
a database system using models,
and how would that
look like if you
put in the end
everything together?
At the core insight is,
that if you have
an efficient model about
your data distribution,
how would you actually build
your data structure or
algorithms with that?
You have an Oracle,
which tells you,
the probability mass given
for a key in your data-set.
Probably this is Oracle,
you would design many
of the algorithms and
data structures you have in
a very, very different way.
The other thing is, it's all
about continuous functions.
If you compare that
now, for example,
to auto preserving
hashing, perfect hashing,
local sensitive hashing, all the
different variants
you have, normally,
they don't take
advantage of the fact
that you can discontinuous
functions much,
much better approximate
the rough position,
so it's like a form of
interpolation search
but often done with
regression or more and
more complex shapes.
If you do that, you have
data structures which learn,
automatically adapt
to the data you
have and they're potentially
run on TPUs or GPUs or FPGAs,
whatever is your preferred
machine learning platform.
In some cases, can even lower
the complexity class for
storage as well as lookup time.
For example, if you saw that in
the case of the data area
look up and I
can also show you
similar things for
the multidimensional
cases now as well.
However, just a warning ahead,
this is not an almighty solution.
There of course datasets,
where still a traditional B-Tree
might be better,
is a lot to be done.
But it's, I think
a very exciting direction.
I'm also very happy to
announce that we are starting
DSAIL for data systems
for AI Lab at MIT,
and that Microsoft is one of
our major sponsors for it.
It involves half systems people,
half ML people from both sides
and the key questions we
are investigating is,
how we can use
machine learning for
systems or build systems
for machine learning?
With that, I think I'am
more or less in time.
I'd like to conclude.
So, what I showed you is
a new approach for indexing.
I think it's
a framework to rethink
many existing data structures
and algorithms and there's
certain conditions that might
change the complexity class
for a particular instance of
the data that's always
important to say,
and the idea might
have implications
within an outside database
systems. Thank you.
>> Any questions?
There is a question.
Peter just, let me
get you a microphone.
>> I can also repeat
it, it's fine.
>> Thank you. So, can
you explain a little bit
about what it
looks like when you're
actually learning
these models versus the process
of building a B-tree?
So, if you're doing
dynamically maintaining
these things on the fly,
it's a little unclear from
your talk what it looks like?
If it gives you a big blob
of data, what do you do?
>> Right. To create an indexer,
what I mainly talked to you about
was only read-only data.
So, the simplest thing is just,
you sort your data and then
if you use for example,
the two-stage linear model,
the top model you can train
in one pass over the data.
Actually you don't even
need the full data,
you can skip pieces of it because
the sample is often
more than enough.
So, it's just one pass
over it because
it's a closed form,
there's no gradient
descent or anything.
Then, what you use is,
you use the top model,
go over all the data
points you have,
put every data point
into the bucket of
what expert it belongs
one level down,
this is our greedy
training approach and
then for every bucket
you repeat the process.
So, you go over the data
as many stages you have.
So, if you have
two stitch models,
you have two passes
over the data.
If you have three stitch models,
three passes over
the data, and so on.
It goes extremely fast.
I mean, a B-tree you can build
in one pass over the data,
if everything is sorted
but the first one doesn't
work on a sample.
Inserts, there's another paper
by Casten and some of
my collaborators
at Brown where we
look into on how we can do
inserts more efficiently.
The easiest way what you do is,
you have a delta index,
instead of doing the inserts
every single time,
retraining them all, you put
them in a delta and then
at some point you figure out
if it's lost by retraining,
or merging, or whatever.
>> There's a question
back there at the end,
and then Jen has a question.
>> So, Tim you're mentioning
that you'd like to know the CDF's
of the single column
distributions in advance.
Isn't that already given to
you by the histograms that
most database systems already
maintained for these columns?
So, I didn't see
you talking about
the interaction
between histograms
and the machine learning process.
>> Right. So histograms are
in the end still
very coarse-grained.
So, the question's, if you
would create a histogram with
the granularity we need for
actual looking the data up,
then it's a question, how do you
browse the histogram itself?
And if you solve that problem,
actually what you
get is a B-tree.
So, I can show that you
can transform one into the
other because you need
the lookup structures over it.
So, histograms themselves
don't help you that much.
There's something
like look-up tables
which was like
the thing in between,
but I had numbers for them,
they also don't
help you that much.
The interesting thing is now,
let's assume I built
my better model for it,
let's say that I model
two stage for the index,
I can use the same
model as my histogram.
So, instead of having histogram,
which I cannot use as an index,
I can use my indexes
as a histogram
and the performance penalty
is almost not existing.
Even better, I can use
the same histograms also to
plug them into
my query optimizer,
I can desalting with them.
Essentially, if I
have one CDF model,
I can use the same model in many,
many different places of
my database system from joining,
sorting, indexing, query
optimization and other things.
The key challenge
though there is,
it's very simple
for one dimension,
it's a little bit harder
for multiple dimensions.
So then, there's
just conditional probabilities
and so on what you do there.
>> Does it work? Back
to Peter's question,
how about other issues
such as locking,
logging, compression
and serialization.
>> Logging, locking,
compression and
serialization.s Let me start
with compression because
it's the best story.
So, let's assume that your index,
given the key, is gives you
the position where
to find that key.
Let's assume my model is
in a way built that I can
ask the reverse question.
Given a position, tell me what
key is most likely there.
If my model would be perfect,
I don't need my keys anymore.
It compresses my data,
essentially, because
given a position,
I know which key I expect there.
Why should I store
the keys anymore?
If the model is not
perfect, what I can do is,
a delta compress against
the expected key
at that position.
So again, the model becomes
my compression technique.
So, that's compression.
Locking, there's a big question
about on how you actually
make B-trees just like
serializable and everything
as everything else.
Arios is just the paper everybody
hates and still everybody uses.
But, in this way because
you deal with the inserts in
a different vein or
approximate fashion anyway,
my assumption is that many of
this complexity of locking
is not actually needed.
I think Microsoft is heavily
looking into that, I heard.
So, they are very, very
excited about that.
Logging is like
transaction processing
and logging is still
something you will need,
because you want still
serializability guarantees
and be everything consistent,
so I doubt that Machine Learning,
at least I cannot
think of an easy
way right now to improve that.
>> Well, with that,
Tim thanks very much
for an exciting talk.
>> Thanks.
Our last speaker for
this session is Matei Zaharia,
and he's a faculty member
at Stanford University,
and previously, he
was at MIT faculty.
During his PhD, as you know,
he started the Apache Spark
computing engine as well as
worked on a number of
open source projects,
such as Mesos.
Apache Spark turned
into a company
that landed a founding
called Databricks,
for which he is the Chief
Technologist as well.
He has had a number of
awards: ACM Doctoral
Dissertation Award,
the VMware Systems
Research Award and
the Daytona Graysort
world record.
More recently, he
has been working
on asking the question,
to have machine learning
and the data scientists be
well-supported on
the data analytic platform,
what needs to happen?
What are the gaps? And he's
going to talk about that today.
So, after having
finished the two talks,
looking at how ML or
the analytic techniques could
help the database internals,
we're going to shift gear and
listen to him to see
what we need to do
to make sure in relation
to the querying
and other things that
analytic systems give,
what you have to do
special to make it
easy for the data
scientist. Matei.
>> Yes.
>> Take it away.
>> All right. Thanks, Surajit.
Let me know if you can't hear me.
Okay. So, yeah, as Surajit said,
I'm going to talk
about infrastructure
for usable machine learning,
and I'll actually start by
talking about a bunch of research
that we're doing in
a lab on this at
Stanford called DAWN.
Microsoft is one of
the generous sponsors of
DAWN, so we appreciate that.
And then, I'll also
briefly put on
my industry hat and
talk about a type of
system that basically
hundreds of organizations are
building in industry and
that there isn't a lot
of research about.
So, I think it's something
that we should look
at as researchers as well,
although I am looking
at it in industry.
So, it's really the golden age
of machine learning.
There are incredible advances
in image recognition,
natural language,
planning, yada yada yada.
It's a great story and
they're starting to
have societies scale impact
every answered that.
But if you look at it
a little bit more carefully,
this statement comes
with a caveat.
So, it's the golden age of
machine learning for
the best funded,
best trained engineering teams.
If you are a company with
tens of thousands of engineers,
it's awesome, you're
happy, you can do it;
but it's still very
difficult for anyone else to
actually use machine
learning and have
any kind of real-world impact.
So, building machine
learning products
is still very difficult
and very expensive.
All the major successes,
the things that actually make it
into products that
make a difference,
things like Siri, or Alexa,
or Autopilot require hundreds
to thousands of engineers
just working on them
continuously to build and
maintain those systems.
And the interesting thing,
if you look at it is,
what are those engineers doing?
Are they all sitting
around a whiteboard doing
integrals and drawing
neural networks and stuff?
They're actually not doing that.
They're not really doing
the stuff you learn in
a machine learning class.
Most of the stuff they're
doing that's really
expensive is data preparation,
quality assurance, debugging
and productionisation.
So, that's what is really
needed to feed these systems,
and it's not modeling.
And so, just a domain expert in
a specific area can't
easily build machine
learning products.
So, if you look at this from
a research perspective,
it's actually
a really interesting
thing to look at because it
means that the problems that
people have in production,
any, say, enterprise user
you talk with you ask,
"Hey, are you using
machine learning?
What's hard?" The problems
that they face are not
the problems that machine
learning researchers
primarily work on.
Those researchers
work on settings
where you already have a dataset,
you already have
a target metric that
everyone agrees is the
right one to optimize,
and you don't even care about
productionizing the model,
you just care about coming
up with a training method;
and that is not what
anyone actually
using this stuff
for real has to do.
So, is this really
a big mismatch where,
as a systems or
data management researcher,
you can go in and have an impact.
We're not the only
ones to say this.
Another example of a paper
that says this is actually
this one from Google,
where they talk about what's
involved in building these
systems and they say,
"Only a fraction of
the real-world ML systems
are the ML code."
All this other stuff around
that is what takes a lot of time,
is expensive, and is hard to do.
So, in the Stanford DAWN Project,
it's a project with
three other PIs: Peter Bailis,
Chris Ré, Kunle and myself.
We're looking at
specifically this problem:
all this stuff needed
around the machine learning
algorithms to build
production applications
to enable domain experts
to build them.
And we want to make
it easy to build them
without the PhD in
machine learning,
but also importantly without
being an expert in systems,
and data management and
hardware to get all
that other infrastructure
around it to work.
So, in this talk, I'm
going to talk about
a few pieces of what
we're building in DAWN,
just to give you examples.
I won't have time to go
into a lot of detail,
but just what are these problems
outside of traditional
machine learning.
And then, I'll also
talk, as I said,
about some stuff happening
in industry in this space.
So, first thing, I'll
talk about, so DAWN,
we were building the
software Stack that
spans all these phases
from data acquisition
to production.
And the first thing I'll talk
about to give you a sense
of what these problems
can look like,
it's actually one of Chris
Ré's projects called Snorkel,
which is at the data
acquisition phase.
And this is about acquiring
or using training data.
So, training data is
obviously the key to
machine learning,
and the places where
it's been most
successful are the places where
it's very easy and cheap
to obtain high volume
training data.
So, image search for images
that occur on the Internet,
not for things, like
medical images.
So much data, you can look at it,
you can build really good models.
Speech: people are
talking all the time.
I'm talking right now,
you can record me,
you could probably build
a model of what I'm going to say.
Games: you just play
some some video games
against yourself,
that's good, you'll
get lots of data.
On the other hand, a lot of
the business applications
that actually matter,
ones were getting labeled
data especially, is
quite expensive.
So, medical images,
you can't just
google them and see lots of
x-rays and start
learning from those,
because there might
not even be that
many patients that have
a certain disease.
Document understanding,
you need, say a lawyer,
to sit down and read
a piece of text and
tell you what the law
would interpret it like,
and that person is going to
cost you thousands
of dollars per hour.
You can't just get
people to click on
things for one cent
an hour and so on.
So, the question in the
Snorkel project is,
how can we leverage data that's
expensive for humans
to label at scale?
And this labeling can
easily be 90 percent of
the cost in many business
applications of machine learning.
So, Chris' project, Snorkel
basically, looks at
a different interface for
labeling which is called
Labeling functions.
So, instead of asking humans
to just give you Labels,
look at all these examples
and give me a zero or one
for each one based on
your expertise as a human.
Despite the Snorkel asked them
to provide Labeling functions,
which are short programs
from a computer
science standpoint
that can give you
a guess at a Label but they
may not always be accurate.
So, for example,
one thing you could do is
you could sit down with
say medical doctors and show them
some notes about patients
and instead of
asking for each one,
is this disease or not?
You can ask them,
hey what do you look for it that
lets you think that
this is heart disease?
Then you can turn that into
a little Python function like
searching for X or
something like that.
Then Snorkel is a training system
that can take a bunch of
these functions and
it simultaneously
learns when each one
is right and wrong,
how noisy it is and the target
model for the data.
So, it can incorporate
this uncertainty from
these functions.
But the benefit of
this interfaces
and just by sitting down
and coding a bunch
of these functions
after you interview
a domain expert,
you can then apply
them to millions of
unlabeled examples and documents.
So, for example,
Chris's group sat down
with with researchers in
the medical school at
Stanford who are
doing these projects
to automatically
understand document
or case notes or things
like that and in
just four hours of
writing stuff with them,
they would match
basically months or
years of hand labeling
these poor grad students
in these fields like part of
their PhD and sitting down
for two years to label documents.
To build an automatic system
for understanding them.
So, that's kind of the impact
obviously saves a lot of
time and money and across
a variety of datasets,
Snorkel can match
basically systems
that have been trained
on labeled data just
by using a bunch of these
functions and millions of
examples that were not labeled
by humans at all before.
So, this is
a very brief overview.
Chris actually has
a whole research program around
this called Data
programming which
is about automatically prepaying,
training data as a kind of
a first-class concept and
it's also all open source.
So, you can find out about it
online but this is an example of
a type of problem that
real users of machine
learning will face.
As another example
of a point problem,
I'll talk about production
and in particular
serving and I'll talk
about this project
NoScope which is
a joint project between
myself and Peter Bailis.
So, machine-learning models
are very accurate.
Especially the new deep
learning one in many cases,
the larger the models
are the more accurate
they are and so people
want to deploy them.
But so many times
the actual inference parses
a is the bottleneck
and it's going to
be the most expensive part.
This is why you see
projects like Brainwave
and so on that try to
accelerate that influence.
So, in this project
we looked at using
CNNs to do queries and video,
something a lot of
people want to do.
CNNs are really good at
recognizing and labeling
objects now but the problem
is these really good CNNs
they're also expensive.
So, they can process
one video stream in real time
on a large server class GPU.
That's what's
considered real time
inference in the computer
vision community
and of course if you
have many say millions
of hours of video are
lots of video streams,
you don't want to stand
up a huge GPU cluster to
monitor and even for
a modest-sized building
this would cost
millions of dollars.
So, in this project, NoScope
will look at how can you
get orders of magnitude faster,
video equates with
a minimal loss in accuracy given
these black box CNN models
that you know are really
accurate about expensive.
So, we use a bunch of
techniques to do this,
but one of the key techniques
is model specialization.
So, basically, we're given
this model that's good
at recognizing things.
You don't really
necessarily need to know
what it does internally and
we're also given a query.
For example, I just want to
count cars that are driving by
my building and we're also
given a bunch of data
to run this query on,
which as you know
this specific video frames
on the camera
outside my building.
So, what we do with this,
is we use this big model.
We label a few samples
from the data with it
and we use it to train
a much smaller specialized model
and this model is
specialized to my query.
It doesn't need to
recognize a pan
dies or motorcycles
or things like that,
it just needs to recognize cars.
It's also specialized to
my data distribution.
For example, maybe my camera
is looking down at the street,
so I don't need to worry about
cars that are flipped upside
down and things like that.
So, these are reasons why from
a machine learning
standpoint you can
have a smaller capacity
model that is pretty
accurate for this
particular query and
the other cool thing
about this model is we
can train it to also
output a confidence score.
So, when it's not sure
about the label of a frame,
we can always call
the original model.
It turns out that by tuning
basically the size of
this model and
the confidence thresholds,
you can actually capture most
of the accuracy of the big model
and still save 99% of
the invocations to it.
So, we also design of
a cost-based optimizer that can
solve this problem
of how exactly which
specialized model to use
and which thresholds.
Basically, the results
from this are that,
depending on
your accuracy target,
you can get large speedups
often an order of magnitude or
more over these original models
and still capture
a lot of the accuracy.
So, we evaluated seven streams
and this first paper
we had on it and
basically decides the best one
where you could go
thousands of times
faster and keep 95 percent
of the accuracy.
Even in the worst sides
you can go about
an order of magnitude faster.
So, it's a pretty powerful
technique to use for inference
and it's easy to apply
probably beyond video as well.
Just as an example of extending
this further and ongoing work
which is unarchive,
we're also extending this to
more complex SQL-like queries
where we see a query
and we use a mix of
techniques including
model specialization
and appoximate
query processing to design
a very fast inference
pipeline for
that query that meets
a certain target accuracy.
So, you can read
about that as well
to see how you can combine
these different things.
It does a little bit
more than just model
specialization and that.
So, that's an example on
the inference side of
the problems that are needed to
actually use these
models in production.
The next step I'll talk about
and the final Dawn example,
I'll talk about is for
software development and
the approach we have
several projects looking at
here is designing
end-to-end compiler that let
productivity programmers get
excellent performance and
have basically built
a production grade application.
So, I'll talk about,
specifically one of my projects
here which is called Weld.
So, if you look at
the data science machine
learning space,
there are a ton of different
processing steps you want to do
with data and there's
a huge ecosystem of libraries,
and also you want to
experiment really quickly.
So, programmer productivity
is super important and
the main technique we
have for a program
or productivity in
general is composition.
It's the only way that we've made
it more efficient to
develop software.
So, ML app developers will
compose functions from
all these high-level libraries,
thousands of Python packages,
R packages, Spark
packages, et cetera.
So, for example, you
might use something like
Pandas in Python to
clean up some data,
you might use NumPy to do
some operations on
it, to normalize it.
Then, you might use
a machine learning library like
Scikit-learn and so you'll be
composing these functions.
Now, the interesting thing
about this is that it
creates an important problem
for optimization
which is even though
each individual function
you call might
be highly optimized
and they often are,
these numerical routines
are very carefully tuned,
your end-to-end pipeline
could be extremely
inefficient, and that's bad.
It means that you're
training will be
slow and then your production
serving will be slow.
In many companies actually
the data scientists
have to throw their
code over a fence to
a production software
engineering team that
rewrites it to make it
efficient and that's
obviously not going to
be cheap or and it's not
something we want to do.
So, the one reason this
happens is just because
the traditional interface
for composing
these libraries
doesn't give you a lot
of room to optimize.
In particular,
most libraries have
these interfaces written in
terms of function calls,
that's the abstraction in
every programming language
and to write a library
that operates on big data,
you give your function pointer to
data that's sitting
somewhere in memory.
That's usually how you
pass things still.
So, this is an example of
a bunch of functions
I'm calling in Python.
I'm going to parse and
then filter some data
and then compute an average
and then this is what
actually happened.
So, these functions in Pandas and
NumPy are actually all hated
and see they're well optimized.
But, what's really
going to happen is
I'm going to call
each one separately and
scan through the
data to read it out
of memory and then write it
back each time I go through it.
So, for example, parse CSV,
the interface is I
give you a pointer to
the input string and I give you
a pointer to an output buffer
and you parse it.
So, has to do
basically two scans through
the data, then dropna.
A again, the interfaces
I gave you an array,
you gave me a new array,
it's doing two to the data
again and finally in the mean,
I'm going to do a single array.
Of course, memory access time
dominates especially
for big data.
So, in a real application,
this can lead to a significant
slowdown and we actually
measure it and just sort
of example workloads
and popular frameworks,
even though each
operator is optimize,
they use dozens of
operators and you get
these very large overheads from
just data movement across them.
So, in the Weld
project at Stanford,
what we're doing is we're
basically designing
a common intermediate
representation and
a common run-time for
data analytics libraries similar
to like a language
virtual machine,
but designed for
data parallel code,
and the idea is these libraries
submits the computation they
want to do to design time engine,
it leisurely collects
the computation from
different libraries
and then it can
optimize it for
different backends,
and this can lead to
significant speed-ups as well.
So, this is an example of
a Pandas and NumPy pipeline,
it's combining operator
is that all written in C,
but if you turn on Weld,
you got around authentic
speedup on one-third.
If you turn on class library
optimization and Weld,
you get another factor of C,
and then Weld's intermediate
language is actually,
it's a functional language
that's data-parallel.
So, it's trivial to
safely parallelize it.
So, you can also turn on
multi-threading underneath
these existing libraries
and get a large speedup.
We have a few papers on the
system and also on how we
optimize underneath it
for real workloads.
Then again, so just
to give you a sense
of some ongoing work,
this shows that okay optimizing
across libraries is
useful and it gives,
we tried to make
this as lightweight
as possible to give users
a really clean and simple
intermediate language
they can write stuff in,
but it's a bunch of
work for them to
instrument and modify
all these libraries to use it.
So, actually in this ongoing work
where we're doing
Weld without world,
we have abstraction called
split-ability annotations,
and this is a way to enable
most of the optimizations
that Weld gives you an
unmodified black-box functions.
We don't even need the source
code of your function.
So, for example in
MKL, the Intel mass,
coronal library, all these
hand optimized routines
for linear algebra.
One of them is actually
adding a bunch of
vectors and they're
really fast and if
my program just
needed to add two vectors,
this would be awesome.
But my program
actually needs to do
hundreds of linear
algebra operations
and these functions
are designed to
take the whole thing at once.
So, it's not that good.
So, what we can do and
this might be my program,
it's adding lots of
vectors together.
What we can do with
split-ability annotations
as we add an annotation
to each function that
says how we can split up
the data to call the function
on little chunks of it.
This is very similar to
vectorized execution and in
databases with little batches.
Is just adding that annotation
to say how we can split this up.
In this case, it means these are
arrays that we're
adding element-wise,
so you can split them
anyway you want into
little chunks as long as
the chunks have
the same shape across them.
So, we have this type system
here that can express more
complicated ways of splitting,
and once you do that,
you can actually get the
significant speed-ups basically
from pipelining underneath
these functions.
So, in this case,
even though MKL itself
is multi-threaded,
it's well optimized and so on,
we got in this case a factor
of eight speedup in various,
this is actually in
the simple workload
but also in a bunch
of real workloads by
pipelining the execution
of them essentially and
it's pretty cool
because we never had to
change the code of MKL.
So, this is still
work in progress but
the interesting result
from this is it can
often get competitive performance
with systems like Weld or XLA,
or other compiler based systems
without rewriting these library.
So, it's a super
lightweight way to
add stuff to an existing library.
So, that's an example
of making programmers
more productive.
Okay, and then the final
bit I'll talk about now
putting on my industry
hat for a bit
is this new type of system for
machine learning guide
industrial scale
which is a machine-learning
platforms,
and what's really interesting
about this is basically,
I think hundreds of companies
are building these platforms.
It's a real need that
actually engineering teams
building these things,
but there's not a lot of research
about it and I think it's
an important system
to know about if
you want to look at
the research in this field,
there's also a lot of unknowns
and ways to innovate here.
So, basically the question
here is if you believe in
machine learning will be
a key part of future products,
what should be the software
development process for it.
So, we see this in a lot
of the companies that I
talk with for example at
Databricks as well
as at Stanford.
They said okay, we had
one or two projects that
were successful with
machine learning but
they took a lot of
time and they were
expensive to do.
How can I have hundreds of teams
in my company using
machine learning?
How can I make it not
just a one-off like
sort of experiments but
something that every team
can reliably use?
And today unfortunately,
just machine learning out
of the box is the development
for it is very ad-hoc.
So, there are a few problems
that make this difficult.
So, one problem is just
tracking experiments.
So, when you do machine learning,
you're going to be running
many variations of your code.
I'm sure in the
previous two talks,
there were many versions
of the models that
didn't work and then finally
use are the ones that did work,
and today, there's
no first class support for
this in the systems you're doing
software development in general.
You have a linear set of gametes.
You never have like
hundreds of branches that
you need to track and
compare with each other.
So, every data scientist has
their own way of
managing experiments.
It's really important to
reproduce the results
and it's also very
difficult because you have
dependencies on datasets,
on code, on parameters,
all over the place and again,
there is no automatic way to
capture them and it's also
difficult to share and manage
models actually for
some companies,
just tracking
which model is deployed,
where did it come from is
a non-trivial problem because
there could be
thousands of models.
So, we need sort
of the equivalent
of software development
platforms if you
think of something like building
a web application or
a mobile application,
there's so much infrastructure
around testing,
IDEs, load balancers,
quality assurance that it's
just there out of the box.
You don't need to worry
about it, but again,
machine learning is
different because of
the wide range of
parameters and experiments.
So, many companies are actually
building a new class
of system to do it
that I'm just going to name
ML platforms because that's
why they named them.
Some of the more prominent
examples that people
wrote blog posts about are
the large web companies,
so Facebook, FBlearner, Uber
Michelangelo Google TFX,
but there are also many of
these at smaller companies and
also even when I talk to
individual machine learning
grad students or researchers,
they say, "Oh, yeah, I have
a Python library that
tries to record
experiments for me."
That's what they're doing.
So, these platforms,
the way these usually
work is there's
an engineering team
that says, okay,
here are the 10
algorithms that you can
use for machine learning and
if you use one of these 10,
we will handle deployment,
we'll handle learning experiments
tuning parameters and so on,
so we'll handle
the whole life cycle.
So, it's good because
they standardized
the life cycle you know that if
you work within this platform,
it will remember
what you did and let
you deploy it and let
your whole backend stuff.
But just having
everyone build their
own is also disadvantageous.
First of all, they're
each limited to
whatever frameworks or algorithms
that company decided to support,
and engineers have
to add a new one,
and second, they're also tied
to this internal infrastructure.
So, you can't do really and share
these things across companies.
So, one of the projects
that I'm working
on at Databricks,
is actually an Open Source,
Open-Interface machine learning
platform that we
launched back in June this year.
It's called MLflow.
And I'll just give you
a sense of what it can do,
but you can read about this
and the other ones online,
just to give you a sense
of the problems.
So, one of the things that it
does is, by Open-Interface,
I mean that it's designed to
work with whatever infrastructure
you have and whatever algorithm,
as opposed to like, "here are
ten algorithms that we support."
So, one of the things it does is,
it lets you package
reproducible projects.
So basically, you can
declare what dependencies,
what environment
your machine learning code
needs in order to run,
and you can also
declare parameters that
other people from outside
can use to call it,
without having to
know the details.
And then in your code,
you use these parameters
and you do your work.
So, that means you can
package your project and
run it again and get
the same results later.
Second component it has,
is experiment tracking.
In your code, you basically use
this REST API to log information,
like here are my parameters,
here are my metrics,
here is the model I built.
There's also a way of
representing a model.
And then, MLflow basically
builds a giant database of
all the experiments
that have been
on for a specific goal,
and you can go back and
re-run a specific one,
or compare them, or pull out
the models and do
something with them.
And then, the third part
in this handle
is deployment, which is,
once I've got a model,
it actually represents models
as basically a function,
very similar to
a serverless function.
And we can then deploy the same
model to many different
'Inference Tools' such as
"Batch" and "Streaming
Inference."
Basically, it's a pretty simple
kind of workflow system,
but it's also something
that has a bunch of
interesting data management
and systems challenges.
How exactly should I represent
projects and dependencies?
How should I represent
the experiments? How
should I equate?
I mean, I can imagine
queries like,
"I had a thousand different
versions of a model,
and I have a new data point,
and I want to know which one
does best on them."
There are a lot of
interesting problems
to look at within this space.
And if you want to read about
this or the other ones,
I think it's an interesting
thing to look at,
because again, people are
actually building these,
like hundreds of companies have
independently decided that
they need to build a platform,
but I don't really see,
when I look at a database class
or something like that,
I don't actually see anyone
talking about
this class of system.
And there's probably
a lot that can be done
to make these things better.
Many open questions left in
designing these platforms.
Okay, so that was kind of
my brief foray into what's
happening in industry.
To conclude, the limiting factors
of machine learning adoption,
are the development
and productionization
tools for many users,
many real users,
especially the ones with
really high impact
business-use cases,
and they're not
the training algorithms.
I think this is
a really great opportunity
for researchers,
including data
management researchers,
because a lot of it
is a data problem,
and they're very unexplored.
You can follow the research we're
doing on DAWN in our blog,
and I'm also happy to
chat with anyone about
problems in this space. Thanks.
>> Of course, we
are running late,
but let's ask if you have
any questions for Matei,
let's take a few.
>> Hey. Thanks for the talk.
I love everything.
>> Yes.
>> I have lots of
questions, but in
the ML platform side
of things, right,
I think especially as
we start applying this
to optimize systems becomes
particularly problematic,
because all of a
sudden, SQL Server
stopped running correctly.
>> All right, yes.
>> Because something
somewhere happened.
And now, I think that beyond
what you're describing,
there seems to be missing sort
of the equivalent of
software engineering practice.
>> Right, yes.
>> In software engineering,
we have like "Find
Bugs" and you know
"Code Reviews" and
all sorts of practices that
kind of protect us from
the worst mistake and socialize
our understanding of what the
system is supposed to do.
Do you have any ideas, beside
tracking the experiments,
like how we get into.
>> That's a great question.
Yes, that's an awesome question.
And yes, I think it
is missing and people
are trying to come up
with best practices,
so just as an example.
So some of the things we want to
enable with MLflow
is to tell people,
"Hey, if you follow this process,
write your code in a project,
submit it this way,
pull out the model this way,
you will get the
following benefits."
Here are some examples
I think I've seen.
One thing I've seen
at one large company,
is they actually have
leader-boards for common tasks.
Let's say you're building
a better language model or
a better image classifier,
there's a single leader-board
in the organization,
where you can see how
others have done over time,
you can submit yours
and you can compare it.
And that's a way that many
people can work on a problem,
and you can see how it's doing.
There's a lot of
interesting stuff with testing.
Is my model doing worse than,
say, a naive linear model?
Is my data drifting in some way?
Are my predictions drifting?
Is the distribution
of the features
I see in production different?
For example, a common thing
is actually you have a bug,
where you didn't load one of
your features into training,
or it didn't get
transformed the same way.
That's another practice.
The other one that is
actually hard to talk about,
but is actually even
defining the metric you
want to change and making
it easy to swap metrics.
One of the things that we
want to do in MLflow is,
if you trained a bunch of models
already and now you want to
change the evaluation metric,
how can we easily let you
switch that and basically add
a column to that table
and compare
them on the new metric. Yes.
>> Other questions?
I think we don't
have the time that we
have set for the panel,
but this is related
to Carlos' question,
and I would ask both you,
Andy and Tim to comment
on it if you have
any thoughts on it.
This is really the software
engineering question,
but sometimes for example,
the kind of work Andy
and Tim are pursuing.
There's always this old-fashioned
database or systems people,
the fear that something
will go wrong in
a robustness sense.
That yes, it's an average case,
it's great, but certainly,
we are going to be
exposed to a variance.
And this is possible
for any system,
but typically in a distributed
system or a database system,
that are guard rails.
That, you know that
you've tripped that fuse,
and we basically say, "Okay,
things are not going well."
Of course, you don't want to
trip the fuse all the time
and have some
discipline around it,
but is this manageable in the
world that we are entering?
And this is also true when we're
building such MLflow and so on,
is there any support we
get from the system,
for understanding this or
experimenting with it
at the last scale?
This is the only question that
I'd like all three of you
to comment on it briefly if
you have any thoughts, right.
Matei, you can go first,
you're just right
here at the podium.
>> Yes. The question is how to
have guardrails for
machine learning,
or getting [inaudible] behavior.
I think it's a good question,
and I think so far,
I've just seen people do
application-specific stuff.
But basically, I think
the most important
things I've seen
are having a fallback,
that is, maybe it gives
you lower quality results,
but it's robust and you can
predict stuff about it.
And then also having some kind of
monitoring that tells you if
things are going haywire.
But the way you do that can
be different in each system.
Yes, I don't think
there's a guarantee.
>> I think I understand
the fact that we
can go to a safer alternative.
>> Yes.
>> But to detect when
we should do that,.
>> Yes.
>> Is sometimes the most
challenging part,right.
>> Yes, it can be.
I think again partly,
just data drift is
the easiest of
these things to capture.
Even that is not super easy.
But like saying, "Hey,
my predictions look
super different,
or my input data look
super different." Yes.
>> And I think it's even harder.
It's not just falling back,
it's falling back gracefully,
because if Machine
learning give us
20x better than where
we were before,
falling back to before
is unacceptable.
>> Yes, definitely.
>> We should smoothly fall back.
>> Yes, just in case you
didn't hear Carlo,
Carlos' point was,
just having a very step function
like alternative to fall back on,
is probably not desirable
for the system to have
some ways to do it gracefully
to the extent possible.
Tim and Andy, if you have
thoughts, come up here.
We'll enable the microphones,
unless you have given it up.
And that will allow
you to speak here.
Are you guys still tied up?
>> I don't know. Yes,
I'm still hooked up.
>> Can you turn
these folks all both on.
>> Sure. They're on.
>> Okay, so
the only thing I would
add from Matei, I
think he's right,
is you have to have
a clear objective function to
determine when some things
are going bad.
But the only thing I
would add is that,
exploitation versus exploration,
I think having
the algorithms be mindful
of what is expected of you
at a given time of
day or week or month,
that way, if it's at nighttime,
when your demand is
low, you can be more
aggressive about trying
different things.
But during the day, when you have
enough SLAs you have to meet
for transactions or your queries,
then you want to be a bit more
conservative and not
try something crazy.
Maybe just not do
any tuning at all, right.
>> Tim?
>> My perspective is
a little bit different,
because we mainly
want to use machine
learning for improving
the systems,
which is a different domain
than if I want
to build a model for
detecting images.
And I think, for example,
for the indexing case,
we particular,
are now looking into
techniques that we
can find bounds for the arrows,
we can get them the best case.
There's this whole field of
blog about smooth analysis,
which allows you to get,
for certain types of
models, guarantees.
And then, you can say, "Okay,
in the worst case, I get the
following behavior," right?
And like, "My model also
grows like a B-tree."
Like the B-tree gives
you a strong guarantee,
because you know in
the moment it goes
like out of balance,
you re-balance
the whole thing to get
the same lookup guarantee again.
There are some machine learning
models where you can do
something similar. There's hope.
For the new net stuff,
it's just like
old nets right now,
and there's not much you can do.
You need to restrict
the tuples modes.
In some domains, you can do that,
and in some others, you can't.
>> Any thoughts, questions
from the audience?
Well, thank you all.
Thank you very much for
a very entertaining session.